the fomc decided to make another
reduction in the pace of his asset
purchases the committee also maintained
its forward guidance regarding the
federal funds rate target and reaffirmed
its view that a highly accommodative
stance of monetary policy remains
appropriate in the labor market
conditions have improved further in
recent months although the pace of job
growth has slowed some
recently job gains have averaged more
than 200,000 per month over the past
three months over the next three years
the projections for real GDP growth runs
somewhat above the estimates of longer
run normal growth the fomc participants
continue to see inflation moving
gradually back toward
2% the central tendency of the inflation
projections is 1.5 to
1.7% in
2014 rising to 1.9 to 2% in 2017 we have
reduced our pace of asset purchases
again at this
meeting starting next month we will be
purchasing $15 billion of Securities per
month down 10 billion per month from our
current rate the committee will end this
program at our next meeting regarding
interest rates the committee reaffirmed
its forward guidance that it likely will
be appropriate to maintain the current
target range for the federal funds rate
for a considerable time after the asset
purchase program ends especially if
projected inflation continues to run
below the committee's 2% longer run goal
and longer term inflation expectations
remain well anchored